so aber immer einladen soll es kommt die
patrone da rein und jetzt ganz misst man
das war ja mal so unspektakulär wie
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer freunde also einer
freunde zu einer folge galaxy zusammen
mit stören wir viel hallo der internet
ist gerade ekelhafte ja ich komme ja
wunderschön ja jetzt bin ich aber darauf
gehe ich bei dir wieder geht es bei dir
wieder mit meinem internet ja jetzt
geht's wieder aber das land oder so eine
prüfung habe ich aber extra gemacht das
war nicht mein internet
weil irgendwie steht bei mir oben links
sondern 08 ein paar mal verwandelt kurz
mein plan für diese folge ist übrigens
dass ich neue fossilien hole mir dann
versuchen einen dino coupé dia zu machen
und wir raketenwerfer patronen zu machen
wäre dein plan ich meine schmelze fertig
und da bin ich ein paar folgen am
tüfteln weil ich endlich der größte
schmelzen mensch bin und damit die leute
wieder ganz viele coole coole tipps
geschrieben weil ich muss jetzt erst so
eine spitzhacke machen und da hin und
her und blaue professor doom eines welt
ja genau okay ganz sicher aus vermot
mensch also war es melanie ich könnte
sagen wie es geschrieben wird nee ich
glaube sogar wirklich so ein ganz klein
bisschen kenne ich mich damit vielleicht
sogar aus und zwar ist das das kannst du
damit so herzer einschmelzen und dann
kannst du irgendwie verdoppeln oder
sowas
ja genau und ich habe jetzt gerade hier
blut drin sehe ich gerade
ich habe gerade mein aluminium
rausgerissen und jetzt habe ich im
original noch 160 blut in das stark im
waldviertel ist essen aber ich habe zwei
raketen werfer
soll ich dann einfach irgendein mob
abschießen zwar machen von raketen werfe
ich habe raketenwerfer und ich habe eine
munition dafür
ich werde ihn benutzt er dauernd ist ein
krieg an entschied jetzt schießt jetzt
mal ab damit achtet mal freunde so aber
immer einladen sollten die patrone da
rein und jetzt ganz misst nur ihr urteil
das war ja mal so unspektakulär das hat
er es gebracht
dieser schuss hat er das hat er echt gar
nichts gebracht
oh mann ich habe auch nicht getroffen
fällt mir grad auf jetzt hab ich hab
neuen hut ich habe luigi hut
ich will auch unbedingt irgendwann mal
auf die akten du musst halt wirklich
einfach nur töten die in gute aufnahmen
ich habe auch ein afro gut mit seinem
der dann so nah wie dann habe ich ein
afro und dann kam in dem afro das geil
aber etwas überlegt den letzten fall
noch mal ein paar gefunden die man echt
ein bisschen irritierend
sie seien einfach nur super merkwürdig
aus ich war ja dass ich dich noch fragen
wollte ist hast du kennst du dich mit
millions aus bisschen an meine sowie
sein können ja die verschwinden immer
wenn du dich aus loks da musst du die
kurz an zusammen und dann okay das habe
ich auch schon gedacht dass ich einfach
angst machen muss
gut dann lese ich muss auch mal jemanden
ich habe gedacht ich mach ja bald seine
1 stunden folge ich kann schon seit drei
wochen der ein stunden folge machen aber
ich muss mich jetzt noch keiner getraut
weil ich ihn nie angst hat dass das
nicht so toll ankommt wenn ich einfach
eine stunde irgendwas mache und vor
allem im internet dass auch extrem lange
grad sagen seht ihr irgendwann dachte
ich das machen soll
könnt ihr bleibt da ist einfach mal so
ein kripo gestern freundlich mal die neu
sein sollte meinen - übrigens abgehauen
weil ich so blöd von mir keiner deen op
dia gemacht habe und ich frag mich die
ganze zeit wird man ihn und alle
zuschauer die wieder auf krawall aus
sind soja der und der dinge cloud ok
muss mark knopfler dinge klar einfach
dass die begründung mir nicht mehr nicht
ich hab ich habe mich wohl das schön
damit liegt auch die nuss zu richten
oder ja oder der sich allmählich kann
man glaubt die pflanzenfresser treffer
ja ich hab ich hatte eine stegosaurus
den aber diesen zweck die die stege de
na ja ich wollte ihn sogar wie folgt ich
habe erst gedacht denn sogar stets mit
den fans noch sehr häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben oder dachten er
wäre vielleicht ein bisschen zu blöd der
natürlichste den aus versehen und alle
sagen du kannst nichts zu töten wollte
china getötet
ok na gut denken dann lassen wir das
auch mal so ich möchte muss fossilien
jagen du kannst nicht zufällig schlafen
oder brauchst du die nacht gerade für
irgendwas nee ich brauche die noch nicht
völlig braucht ihr noch nicht gerade auf
dem bett oder wie jetzt auch wieder mal
stellen wo ich sagen sogar die sonne
gerade auf von daher ich könnte mich
auch hinlegen ich liege du liegst okay
lass mal hinlegen
rolf ja jetzt ist es ja egal erzählt ihr
die sonne ihr gerade auf oder wenn ich
mich zurück warnt verwandelt dann ist
das aber doppelt hof du kannst also aus
dem bett aussteigen ach komm ich liege
gerade die stadt verbleibt schon liegen
bleibe ich ihnen meine größten
zeitsprung aufgestellt wie seit tagen
eine vignette ist sich alles mal
schmutzig werden und ich stehe dazu dass
ich komme
ich mache jetzt übrigens nur noch kaffee
bohnen und esse die nur noch davon
kriegt zwar nicht so viel essen aber die
katze so leicht anpflanzen und davon
kannst du so viel im inventar bild haben
recht gut
warum ist dieser wasserfall jede folge
aufs neue wieder da ich mache denn jedes
mal zu weil die so unglaublich laut ist
ja deswegen hab ich auch so auf dass er
einfach so richtig viele wasserfälle
sind und die sind alle so unglaublich
lauer und wenn ihr den weg macht ist
halt immer noch die geräuschkulisse dann
als ob herrlich ist echt kein wasser
fall aber geräusche hier wieder jedes
mal jede folge aufs neue so stark
endgültig richtig krankhaft laut freude
was ich übrigens mal ganz kurz machen
wollte ist ich weiß nicht ob ich mir
dazu ein schild aufstellen das ist dass
wir jemanden der ein stunden voll
gemacht ich glaube ich brauche jetzt
einfach ich nehme ich jetzt mal ganz
kurzen zettel habe ich ein stift nämlich
nicht doch wo gott dann schreiben wir
ganz gut sachen für die ein stunden
folge auf leute die ich dann da mache
verlässt man blatt nach unten
1 stunde folge so ich mache mir
unterirdisch unterirdische farben plus
kisten zeichnen wir das immer ganz kurz
auf die kinos bringen
und da soll ich wirklich gern zeigen
aber das ist irgendwie so dass stets
meine stadt drauf wo ich wohne
denn du und zwar weil ich das ganze was
hier ist weil ich so kleinen weg nach
unten machen
oder macht das hier unten rein hier wo
das hier ist man kommt also eine riesige
unterirdische farben weil es gezeigt ihr
elend ich gelesen die letzten kommentare
bis dato deswegen hab ich gerade so ein
bisschen ein bisschen auch in meinem
haus weiter nur damit die leute sich
hier nicht wundern was ich mache mehr
nicht eingespielt eigentlich geschrieben
wie das alles geht wo nach lette letzte
folge fragte aber ich wie gesagt bei
jetzt sehr viel unterwegs die tage und
kann bald nicht so vertieft in die
kommentare
deswegen muss ich noch mal mit ein
bisschen rein lesen bevor ich hier
weiter schmelzen
deswegen mach ich jetzt aber auch mal
ein bisschen die brustschwimmer meine
min jetzt wieder da habe ich jetzt
einfach hier so gemacht du malst jetzt
also wenn ich jetzt quasi einfach die
jetzt hier so hinsetzte sag ich mal
moment so so die kommen hier hin alle
jetzt wirklich jetzt nämlich z
jetzt mache ich mit meinen schwestern
bei rechtsklick jetzt kommt jedoch
hierhin sie bloß mach ich alter akten
mehrheit müssen die rechte gemeinschaft
und ein rechtsklick hier kommt keiner
sieht ihn wieder da oder diese auf dem
weg oder kann ich auch ganz kurz an
zusammen machen oder wie das ankommt
augen machen wenn ihr noch nicht gemeint
haben
ansonsten einzel sachen jetzt sind sie
da irgendwie jetzt so einer daten sind
wie sie verpackt alles ich komme gar
nicht gleich noch mal eben kurz
ansammeln und jetzt mal wieder komplett
live jetzt kurz alles schwarz das normal
jetzt ist aber nur ein wenn aber dass
mir relativ egal sei was die
gemeinschaft rechtsklick aber es
passiert nichts weg
negativ los doch ohne burke macht geholt
oder die macher vordersitzen oder die
strippen jetzt einfach mal gesagt ob
damit jetzt hier
so hat genießt unterschwellig das schön
dass wir wieder von meinen minions
irgendwie sonst auto aber liest erkennst
du hast wenn du die sachen in den
inventar liegen will den moment aber
voll ist und das nicht passiert
verzweifelt weiterhin versuchen indem
italease würde die nicht erst wenn du
ins verbacken mensch bist kannst du
nicht tschüss so ein reh kommt jetzt
guck mal hier ich mache dir rechtsklick
und jetzt sind ja auch meine minions das
ist ja mal wunderschön jetzt wirklich
strip main soll sind die beispielsweise
diesen gang hier rechtsklick es geht
einfach es passiert nichts doch
irgendwie grip da gerade weil sind oder
wer ist das wie komisch graben die
besoffen wenn die wenn du so auf einer
ungeraden ebene anfängst machen die
glaube ich es mit der erde auf sowas
oder das nicht so die machen halt
irgendwas aber irgendwie jetzt halt mal
aufgehört
jetzt sind aber mal richtig komisch wie
die graf
und wenn ich jetzt eine kiste habt dann
kann ich da einfach wie kann ich das
jetzt mit der kiste machen wie shift und
rechtsklick müsste das nein
so wurde mir das auf jeden fall schon
häufig erklärt hat bei mir lustigerweise
aber auch noch nie funktioniert
das hört dann ist es das aber soll wohl
so gehen meint auch gemeint aufs parkett
erst mal dann stimmt das auch dann wenn
du ins park was sagt denn sonst park was
sagt dann ist das gesetz dann kommt ihr
gerade jetzt hier ich will jetzt nicht
zum blöden mine shafter ansammeln
millions komitee evtl
jetzt kommt wieder ein
sonst sound hier und jetzt mache ich
rechtsklick und jetzt kommen die medien
soll das funktioniert ja schon mal alles
super jetzt hab ich hier drei stück als
brauche ich wieder hunger wieder hungern
bis dass das schlecht gelöst
er ist super scheiße formiert so jetzt
fresse ich jetzt ein paar kaffeebohnen
dass auch geil einfach so kopf kakao
kaffee bohnen einfach essen könnte oder
der von hannover wäre angenehm mensch
solche vier stück soll ja ja bla bla
die gemeinschaft hier greift ihr jetzt
stark die graben jetzt soll dann klappt
ja schon mal alles der eine ist ein
bisschen verpackt aber so ist das hier
die kiste hinter jetzt wirklich shift
und rechtsklick mit dem mit dem start in
die mit irgendwas gesagt alles klar oder
eben jetzt graben die da und ich hoffe
ihr holt mir ganz ganz viele fossilien
da war ich auch schon recht lange auf
der suche hast du freche lieder gemacht
waren am anfang ich habe mehrere dna
sache nicht von terex und das sogar
schon das 1
das ist kann ich aber halt noch nicht
setzen weil man braucht ja irgendwie
auch aus der archäologie motto ja so die
lupe
ja genau die pda und man braucht auch so
einen speziellen käfig für den weil der
wirt recht schnell recht groß und der
wasserreichste und ihr ex-mann mal ein
ganz normaler terex gescannt ihrig sich
tom clark einige tracks aber das ist
krass
fast flip ja dann so ein bisschen aus
ganz schnell habe ich mir sagen lassen
deswegen sollte ich den noch nicht
setzen außer wenn ich mir wirklich viel
kaputt und so ja genau
also ist auch nicht so zweimal genossen
faustregel von das schön so bitte komm
ja ganz viele fossilien raus da kommt es
schon irgendwelche sachen die wir dann
ja ich habe eine schwert und helm
damit wollte ich mir auch coole rüstung
machen
aber ich weiß nicht was genau sich die
besser als irgendwas oder oder wie ich
weiß es nicht
beim hellmann ich informiert bin
generell was rüstung angeht wieso noch
nicht so ganz im bilde sich weiß dass
man mit diesem tinkers construct ja so
richtig krasse waffen bauen kann also
siehe 19 tag der milch und sowas ja da
wollte ich mir auch noch was ganz cooles
bauen wie möglich da noch überall
darüber informieren er ist immer dieses
rein lesen willst dann musst du
irgendwie eine sache bis so ein bisschen
dran und dann wirst du beim nächsten
schon dass er irgendwas anderes cooles
macht und denkst oh ja ich bin bald
dieser der das kku gemacht das binden
das bin übrigens www auch alle mitte
sind wir ganz ganz vorne mit dabei der
beiden bei den coolen sachen genau
dieser nochmals spitzen sieht aber auch
schon ein bisschen besser aus wenigstens
nicht gut aber besser
ich würde mich am liebsten mit dem
hausbau beschäftigen oder sagt jeder
wieder auch hausbau gibt auch erstmal
ein bisschen ein bisschen gewusst aber
einfach nur bei mir auch aussieht
es ist echt nicht mehr feierlich ich
will jetzt nur spielen
ich habe drei fossilien ich hoffe mal
dass er als irgendwas cooles rauskriegen
dass wir nicht so feierlich wenn da
einfach jetzt zwei cds herauskommen
würden das würde ich einmal so feiern
bekommt jetzt erstmal meinen la la la la
mal schauen was da rauskommt in der
zwischenzeit nämlich in der zwischenzeit
das ist ja schon fast fertig ja doch
kommen dann zwischenzeitlich mal ganz
klein minions hier wasser sei diese von
sieht die kann man anbauen für die
pflanzenfressenden dinosauriern
aber nur unter bäumen ok also im schach
weiß nicht unter welchem das ist ding
also weißt du gar nichts doch du
blödmann nicht weil die juden geil aber
die ganze zeit fossilien ab und es kommt
einfach nichts raus außer knochen
hier komme nicht nur knochen noch aus
was soll länder darüber beraten relikt
gießen
ach das ist doch alles zu krass gewesen
dass diamanten
ich lebe auch ihnen grundsätzlich
diamanten mit weil ich einfach denke
diamanten sind diamant und die sind
gerade aber sie sind hier überhaupt
nicht wertvoll und hier so richtig viele
fossile das sehr schön
ich habe es gesagt ich beschäftige mich
als erstes mal hier mit dino server dass
er sich ganz cool an jedes coolsten
sachen die man machen kann besonders die
noch halt schneller dann muss die
fossilien finden und dann kannst direct
kürt müssen wir diese komischen drei
gerätschaften ja eine stimme aus der sie
nur nicht so erwartet sechzigste dna und
packte ein buch drauf und dann kann ich
mir das buch ich behindert
jetzt fehlt mir noch ein buch mit leder
leder & paper tatsächlich ein buch und
ich habe jetzt eine den op dia soll das
ist ja wundervoll so und jetzt habe ich
sogar keine weitere dino dna das ist
toll
dafür brauche ich auch noch zähne
reliquien wurden wie gesagt für dungeons
taktisch wert ja ja genau da brauchst
genau 10 für mich im livestream gemacht
der braker total war bitte klappt es und
dann habe ich die leute schon
angeschrieben dass die mich belogen
haben als es nicht so aus als würde es
aufgehen und dann hatten sie aber doch
recht weil es so ganz knapp
geht das mit den relikten ok cool und
stand mal in folge beenden
beenden wir hier wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann lasst meine bewertung da und
schreibt alles eine kommentare was uns
cool machen könnte und was uns tipps
gibt es von meiner seite